INDEPENDENT OF US BUT WE HAVE
GONE THROUGH A LOT OF INTERVIEWS
AND WHEN THEY WRAP UP, THEY
SHOULD WRAP IT UP RATHER THAN
JUST KEEP SEARCHING TO HELP
DEFINE SOMETHING.
AT
HOPEFUL THINKING AGAINST
DEMOCRATS WHICH THEY POLITICALLY
APPEAR TO OPPOSE.
>> Bret: THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME.
WE TOLD YOU THAT NORTH KOREA IS
AGAIN THREATENING TO CANCEL NEXT
MONTH SCHEDULED SUMMIT BETWEEN
KIM JONG UN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BUT CHINA IS PUTTING PRESSURE ON
KIM TO SAY     STAY THE COURSE.
LET'S GET MORE TONIGHT FROM
GREG PALKOT.
>> Reporter: MORE DIPLOMATIC
HARDBALL FROM NORTH KOREAN
LEADER KIM JONG UN.
HIS VICE FOREIGN MINISTER SAYING
IN A STATEMENT LATE WEDNESDAY
KOREA TIME, WE ARE NO LONGER
INTERESTED IN A NEGOTIATION THAT
WILL BE ALL ABOUT DRIVING US
INTO A CORNER AND MAKING A
ONE-SIDED DEMAND TO GIVE UP OUR
NUKES.
AS THE CHINESE PRESIDENT GREETED
IN BEIJING AND VISITED
NORTH KOREAN DELEGATION, THE
NORTH KOREAN ALLY URGED
PYONGYANG NOT TO GIVE UP TALKS
NEXT MONTH WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TRANSLATOR MACK NORTH KOREA AND
THE U.S. SHOULD MEET EACH OTHER
HALF WAY AND DEMONSTRATE MUTUAL
SINCERITY TO CREATE A CONDUCTIVE
ATMOSPHERE FOR THE LEADERS
MEETING AND, THE REGIME HAD
ALREADY BRANDED AIR EXERCISES AS
PROVOCATIVE AND CALLED OFF A
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMZ
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMB
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMT
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DME
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMN
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMR
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMH
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMA
MEETING SET FOR TODAY AT THE DMD
SOUTH KOREAN OFFICIALS.
AND SEWALL, TOO, WAS UPSET.
WE URGE THEM TO COME UP WITH
TALKS MEDIALLY FOR PEACE AND
PROSPERITY.
MOST THINK THAT KIM JONG UN DOES
NOT WANT TO PULL OUT OF THE
SUMMIT AND THIS IS MORE
POSTURING AND POSITIONING BEFORE
NEGOTIATIONS.
THOSE IN WASHINGTON SAY THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD STICK TO HIS
GUNS.
>> I WOULD ADVISE AND CAUTION
NOT TO GIVE INTO THEIR
CONCESSIONS BEFORE YOU CAN GET
TO THE NEGOTIATING TABLE.
YOU WANT TO NEGOTIATE OUT OF
STRENGTH, NOT WEAKNESS.
>> NORTH KOREA IS A PUBLIC
DISMANTLING OF ITS ONLY KNOWN
NUCLEAR TEST SITE IS SET FOR
NEXT WEEK.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT HAPPENS IT
COULD BE A SIGN OF HOW REAL THIS
IS.
>> STILL THE LATEST STATEMENT
FROM NORTH KOREA DOES INDICATE
THE POSSIBILITY THAT THEY MAY
WANT TO REJECT THE DEMAND FOR
DENUCLEARIZATION.